when we launched Alan we got to just
under 2 million a month we did in six
months because I got three super
influencers on board it was the easiest
thing to do there are influencers right
now that are influencers of influencers
to people who like teach how to create
you know YouTube videos they have
audiences of influencers go to a super
affiliate who has an audience of all of
the people so if you have two levels of
Leverage one is because you have this
person and then you have all the
leverage that they have and all their
customers and so it's like how do I make
a deal with this guy and then rather
than selling agency owners directly I
was like well who has an audience of
agency owners I said that I sold those
guys and then I just gave them a rip off
the top line for everything Downstream
and so like three sales ended up
generating thousands of businesses that
joined the platform